the Joe Rogan experience hey Harry block
tell me those UFOs that sound they're
actually drones Russian and China drones
they think did you hear that just once
no I think you would you post leave his
favor ones they found in [ __ ] San
Diego that went from like 60 feet above
the water drone Sundra he's in a second
groans Joe no they don't even know what
the propulsion system of these things so
the government told us dude listen
[ __ ] you're coming after us for this
[ __ ] you guys are doing the same
[ __ ] if that is a drone if that is a
drone that commander Frey verse aw
that's off the coast of San Diego where
they scrambled to go meet this thing it
was hovering over the water it moved so
fast they could barely track a Chinese
violated all sorts of laws repulsion and
speed not necessarily aliens they don't
know what the [ __ ] it is but here's the
thing the people that are there at the
front of the line of propulsion don't
understand it
well this is why this is what this is
why it's confusing the only way they'd
be able to make this in secret
scientists the way they work is one
scientists paper influences the work of
another scientist they figure things out
together they're all in coordination
cool because they have to exchange
information because one guy can't be the
[ __ ] guy who lives in the middle of
the mountain that's a super genius like
in ex machina who makes his own people
and no one else is aware in the reality
the real worlds like this all work with
a bunch of other side so there's there's
not gonna be a thing that just sneaks up
on someone that's that monumental where
it just gets built and all of them are
like what the [ __ ] yeah
but it Brian I'm not going batshit crazy
or didn't they tell us it was drunk okay
listen man those things were moving in a
way that they don't understand
there's always last time for people good
point but the people that understand
propulsion know that there's got to be
something that makes them go there's no
heat signature the others know the
latent pointer and erasing it they're
tracing it on radar yeah they don't know
anything all these dudes
maybe Holograms have fun with different
weapons systems that they use to lock in
on physical targets she doesn't even
come up it moves on radar faster than
the kitten they got video this thing
must read video so I wanted to talk to
him about it how dare you
dude I wish I did now that you brought
up I feel like a [ __ ] up why didn't I
ask him you know he knows you're right
Wow he probably has his own weirdo
theater oh my gosh I'm one of those
drones Joe it's probably and the bars I
hear next time so he does instead of
sleeping yes yes to pretend he's
sleeping this
[Applause]